OUTBREAK ABOUT RACE.
CANDACE OWENS FIRES BACK.
BUT FIRST, MY THOUGHTS AT THE
END OF DAY 29, AMERICA IN
SHUTDOWN.
WE KNOW TOO MANY AMERICANS
CONTINUE TO DIE TODAY OF THE
NOVEL CORONAVIRUS BUT WE ALSO
WITNESSED THE FLATTENING OF THE
COVID-19 CURVE.
AND THUS, IT WAS NOT SURPRISING
THAT WE ARE THE STRONGEST
INDICATION YET THAT THE
WHITE HOUSE IS READY TO GREEN
LIGHT THE REOPENING OF LARGE
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY.
>> THE PLANS TO REOPEN THE
COUNTRY ARE CLOSE TO BEING
FINALIZED.
CERTAIN STATES, AS YOU KNOW, ARE
IN MUCH DIFFERENT CONDITION AND
IN A MUCH DIFFERENT PLACE.
IT’S GOING TO BE VERY, VERY
CLOSE, MAYBE EVEN BEFORE THE
DATE OF MAY 1ST.
>> Laura: I THINK WE ARE
TALKING A COUPLE DAYS IF I CAN
READ BETWEEN THE LINES THERE.
IT’S CLEAR THE PRESIDENT NEVER
CONTEMPLATED MANDATING A
ONE-SIZE-FITS-ALL APPROACH TO
REOPENING.
HE DIDN’T DO THAT FOR THE
SHUTDOWN, AFTER ALL, HE LET
STATES DECIDE.
BECAUSE THAT WOULD BE INSANE,
BECAUSE NEW YORK IS NOT THE SAME
AS OTHER STATES.
REMEMBER, IT WAS TWO WEEKS AGO
THAT GOVERNOR CUOMO AND HEALTH
EXPERTS WERE FEARMONGERING THAT
THE ENTIRE NATION WOULD SOON
LOOK LIKE NEW YORK.
THESE HORRIFIC IMAGES OF
REFRIGERATOR TRUCKS LINED UP
OUTSIDE HOSPITALS
COAST-TO-COAST.
OF COURSE, THAT WAS INSANE AND
WE CALLED IT OUT OF THE TIME
BECAUSE WE KNEW THAT WAS NOT
CORRECT.
FOR WEEKS WE’VE ALSO TOLD YOU
THAT THE COVID MODELS WERE ALL
WRONG.
THE MORTALITY NUMBERS ARE FAR
BELOW, THANKFULLY, INITIAL
PROJECTIONS.
PROJECTIONS THAT WE HAVE TO
REMEMBER SPURRED GOVERNORS TO
INSTITUTE THE STAY-AT-HOME
ORDERS AND MOST OF AMERICA.
I THINK IT’S FAIR TO SAY THAT
CLOSING BUSINESSES AND SCHOOLS
AND UNDOUBTEDLY BOTH SAVED AND
RUINED LIVES.
THROUGHOUT THE CRISIS, ORDINARY
CITIZENS AND COURTS ARE NOW
STARTING TO CHALLENGE AND REJECT
SOME OF THE HEAVY-HANDED AND
ARBITRARY MOVES BY STATE
OFFICIALS.
MICHIGAN
GOVERNOR GRETCHEN WHITMER I’M A
KENTUCKY GOVERNOR STEVE BASHIR,
BOTH DEMOCRATS, ARE COMING UNDER
INCREASING SCRUTINY FOR THEIR RE
SHUTDOWN MOVES.
THE ANGLE HAS URGED THE
STATEHOUSES IN BOTH STATES TO
COME BACK INTO SESSION TO
CHALLENGE THESE ACTIONS, BUT SO
FAR, EVEN THOUGH THESE ARE
REPUBLICAN MAJORITIES, IN MOST
STATES THEIR M.I.A.
WE DID, HOWEVER -- THIS IS
GOOD -- SEE SIGNS OF LIFE IN
PENNSYLVANIA TODAY.
BY A VOTE OF 107-95, REPUBLICANS
PASSED A BILL TO OVERTURN
DEMOCRAT GOVERNOR TOM WOLF’S
STRICT BUSINESS SHUTDOWN RULES
WHICH WERE FAR MORE SEVERE THAN
THE FEDERAL GUIDELINES.
IT’S ABOUT TIME.
THEIR THINKING IS THAT SINCE THE
VIRUS WILL PROBABLY BE A THREAT
FOR MONTHS OR YEARS, IT’S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE A VISION.
IT’S IMPORTANT WE HAVE A PLAN TO
GET BACK TO WORK.
CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM
THING C HAS A PLAN TO GET HIS
STATE BACK TO WORK, KIND OF,
COULD ACTUALLY BE A PLAN TO
AVOID A RETURN TO NORMALCY?
WHILE, IN THE GOLDEN STATE, MORE
THAN 780 HAVE DIED DUE TO THE
CORONAVIRUS AND AS TRAGIC AS ANY
AND ALL LOSS OF LIFE IS, AND IT
SURE IS, THAT FIGURE IS
ASTONISHINGLY LOW FOR A STATE OF
40 MILLION PEOPLE.
NOW COMPARE THAT TO THE NUMBERS
IN NEW YORK, A STATE WITH HALF
THE POPULATION AND MORE THAN TEN
TIMES THE COVID DEATHS.
YET TODAY, GAVIN NEWSOM INSISTED
THAT THE STATE COULD ONLY BEGIN
TO REOPEN IF SIX DISTINCT
CONDITIONS WERE MET.
THEY ARE QUITE INVOLVED AND
PERHAPS NOT REALISTIC, WE WILL
GET INTO MORE OF THAT WITH
HOME DEPOT COFOUNDER BERNIE
MARCUS.
BY THE WAY, WITH HANNITY, IF,
LIKE ME, YOU REALLY MISS
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL OR THE NBA
OR OTHER PROFESSIONAL SPORTS,
COLLEGE SPORTS, YOU’RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO COLLEGE FOOTBALL IN
THE FALL LIKE I AM, WELL, DON’T
LOOK FOR ANY HOPE FROM GAVIN
NEWSOM.
>> LARGE-SCALE EVENTS THAT BRING
IN HUNDREDS, THOUSANDS, TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF STRANGERS
ALTOGETHER ACROSS EVERY
CONCEIVABLE DIFFERENCE, HEALTH
AND OTHERWISE IS NOT IN THE
CARDS BASED UPON OUR CURRENT
GUIDELINES AND CURRENT
EXPECTATIONS.
>> Laura: WELL, LOOK,
CALIFORNIANS ARE JUST GOING TO
HAVE TO DECIPHER THEMSELVES
DECIDE FOR THEMSELVES HOW MUCH
OF THEIR FREEDOM, THEIR WORK,
THEIR SCHOOLING, THEIR LEISURE,
THE FAMILY TIME THEY’RE WILLING
TO SACRIFICE GOING FORWARD FOR
THE PROMISE OF SAFETY FROM A
VIRUS THAT SO FAR, WE DID THE
MATH, HAS KILLED .002% OF THE
STATE’S POPULATION.
AND THOSE ARE MY THOUGHTS AT THE